say that my good friend and neighbor
from New Hampshire senator Gregg I took
to the floor yesterday to his express
his outrage there ten senators on the
Budget Committee voted for amendment
that I offered which lost by the way 12
to 10 to begin the process begin the
process of breaking up too big to fail
financial institutions that pose a
catastrophic risk to our economy and
quite frankly after listening to a
senator Gregg statement I wonder with
all due sincerity what planet are he is
living on apparently he has missed the
fact that due to the greed the
recklessness and the illegal behavior of
Wall Street that the American people
continue to suffer through the worst
economic crisis since the Great
Depression the damage done by Wall
Street in bringing this economy to a
grinding halt is incomprehensible
millions of people having lost their
jobs their homes their savings young
people trying to get go out to the job
market to begin a career in their lives
unable to do that because of the greed
of Wall Street and the fact that just
yesterday we could not get one
Republican vote to proceed to begin the
debate on how we finally reform Wall
Street is beyond my comprehension this
debate needs to be going forward and we
need to pass strong underlying strong
legislation that make sure that what
happened a year and a half ago never
ever happens again and mr. president I
also find it interesting that we have
some of our conservative Republican
senators like Senator Gregg who day
after day tell us how much they dislike
big government don't like Social
Security don't like medica don't like
big government but apparently they have
no problem with you
huge financial institutions which
control a very significant part of our
economy in the last 15 years the sixth
largest banks in this country have more
than tripled in size and now have
combined assets equal to sixty-three
percent of the gross domestic product
let me say that again those six largest
banks in this country now have combined
assets equal to sixty-three percent of
this nation's gdp so all of my
conservative friends will come down all
government is too big government is
awful what about banks that have
trillions of dollars in assets why
aren't we talking about that reality the
truth is that today what we are seeing
with these huge financial institutions
is not only the ongoing problem of what
happens when they fail and whether the
taxpayers will be having to bail them
out again but when you have that kind of
concentration of ownership you have a
very very dangerous situation mr.
president the four largest banks in this
country for banks issue two-thirds of
the credit cards now what do we think
about that everybody in the world is a
credit card for banks issue two-thirds
of that now how does that tally with the
rhetoric I hear from my conservative
friends about a competitive economy
competition is what drive prices down
well maybe one of the reasons that
millions of Americans today are paying
twenty five or thirty percent interest
rates on their credit cards is that you
have four banks that issue two-thirds of
them mr. president the four largest
banks in this country provide half
of the mortgages in America I think that
that is a real problem the four largest
banks control nearly forty percent of
all bank deposits in this country now
over a hundred years ago we had some
good Republicans William Howard Taft and
Teddy Roosevelt and what they said when
they saw the concentration of ownership
and wealth that existed in that time
they is good Republicans they said let's
start breaking it up and I think what
they did over a hundred years ago is a
lesson that we should learn today if a
financial institution is too big to fail
that financial institution is too big to
exist and the time is now to start
breaking them up mr. president this idea
of starting to break up large financial
institutions it's not just an idea that
Bernie Sanders had it's not just an idea
that an amendment offered by Senators
Brown and Kaufman is going to speak to
it's an idea that is spreading all over
this country I would point out to you
that the presidents of three regional
Federal Reserve banks also support the
need to start breaking up large
financial institutions they are James
board who is the president of the Fed in
st. Louis Thomas honig the president of
the Fed in Kansas City and Richard
Fisher the president of the Fed in
dallas texas and they are all in general
agreement that we have got to start
breaking up these large financial
institutions mr. president
senator Dorgan made this point and I
want to make it again and that is that
during the bailout the Fed decided that
it was going to lend out trillions of
dollars in zero or almost zero interest
loans and when Chairman Bernanke came
before the Budget Committee on which I
serve I asked them what I thought was a
pretty simple and straightforward
question and that is mr. chairman can
you tell me and the American people who
received these loans I mean we're
talking about trillions of dollars and
loans I don't think it's too much to ask
who received the loans what the terms
were of those loans well mr. Bernanke
disagreed and I offered an amendment
that day or that begins to bring
transparency to the Fed and that
amendment is called the Federal Reserve
Sunshine Act and I am happy to say mr.
president that it has 32 co-sponsors
interestingly enough 22 of them were
Republicans ten are Democrats and they
are centered a bra so Bennett of Utah
box of Brownback burr caught in
Chambliss Coburn Cochran Cornyn Crapo
DeMint dog and Feingold Graham Grassley
Harkin hatch Hutchinson Inhofe Isaacson
Landrieu Leahy Lincoln McCain Murkowski
rich soon vitta web wicker and widen
that is quite a cross-section of
political views in favor of bringing
transparency to the Fed and mr.
president what my amendment will do and
we intend to bring that amendment to the
floor during this debate is in fact
would require the federal reserve to
release all of the details about the
more than two trillion dollars in zero
interest loans that the Fed provided to
large financial institutions and also it
would call for a Gao audit of the Fed
and
the bottom line there mr. president is
that it is imperative that the Geo ajo
conduct an independent and comprehensive
audit of the Federal Reserve within one
year and that's what our amendment does
it requires the federal reserve to
disclose the names of the financial
institutions that received over 2
trillion dollars and virtually zero
interest loans since the start of the
recession and mr. president this is an
amendment that I think millions of
people wanted was interesting about it
is you talk about bipartisanship or try
partisanship this amendment both in the
house and the Senate brings together
some of the more conservative members
and some of the more progressive members
in the house this language is supported
by by former colleague Ron Paul and I'm
introducing it here in the Senate and
that my friends is a very significant
disparity in political views but we do
agree that the Fed needs transparency so
mr. president let me conclude by simply
saying this the time is now for the
United States Senate to begin to deal
with the greed the recklessness and in
the illegal behavior on Wall Street the
American people have demanded action
since this crisis began and we owe it to
them to deliver our and as we proceed
with Senator dogs piece of legislation
which I think has many many very
positive attributes I think our goal as
the debate continues is to make it even
stronger and in that regard as I just
mentioned i will be bringing forth an
amendment dealing with fed transparency
i will be bringing forth an amendment
which will put a cap on the interest
rates that banks can charge i think it
is not acceptable not moral that banks
are now charging twenty-five thirty
percent interest rates we're going to
have a cap similar to what exists for
credit unions and as i mentioned also
where
going to have legislation and amendment
dealing with Fed transparency so mr.
president my hope is that our Republican
friends will join us in beginning this
debate and in fact going forward so that
finally finally we can hold Wall Street
accountable and bring forth the
legislation to make sure that never
again that we see a repetition of the
disaster that we saw a year and a half
ago with that was the president I would
yoga for vice president senator from
Kansas surprised i understand i have ten
minutes in which to make my remarks is
that correct the center can be
recognized for ten minutes I appreciate
that thank you mr. president over the
past two years Americans have seen an
unprecedented government reach into the
private sector some of which may be
necessary they're angry about it however
as they should be as it touches their
individual lives and pocketbooks for
many the overreach of government began
with a bank bailout or tarp for short a
Terp the seven hundred billion tarp that
I opposed was passed in the fall of two
thousand eight when every day we awoke
to see a new financial crisis headlining
the front page now tarp was initially
intended to purchase the troubled assets
and get them off the books of the
troubled banks yet over time the program
evolved into a fund some would call it a
slush fund to include bailouts for the
auto industry and the housing market the
term bailout will never be the same
again I think the American people are
right mr. president to demand that they
are never again put on the hook to bail
out a failed company they are right to
demand that those who got us into the
financial mess not be allowed to do so
again unfortunately unfortunately the
financial regulatory reform bill that
the Senate is set to take up and eBay
does not achieve these goals I know both
sides are now involved in in discussions
and the next 48 hours is going to be
absolutely crucial to determine if in
fact we can get a bipartisan bill but
with as any business if it is mismanaged
if its leaders make poor decisions the
business should be allowed to fail
success and failure have until recently
been the cornerstone of what has made
our economy one of the strongest in the
world the bailouts of financial an auto
companies have turned that philosophy on
its head and I think it is a dangerous
road we need to set a new course it is
what the American people want this bill
does not end bailouts instead it allows
some of the largest financial
institutions to contribute to a bailout
fund to be used if a company were again
to fail well this does nothing to deter
companies from taking risks that could
lead to failure and the need for a
future bailout in fact it sends a signal
that the government will bail out
institutions just as it bailed out
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac the two
troubled mortgage giants that have
received 120 5.9 miles will make it one
hundred and twenty six billion dollars
in direct government funding and now
have an unlimited us credit line yet
there's no mention no mention no mention
of fannie or freddie in this bill
failure to deal with fannie and freddie
keeps taxpayers on the hook for more
bailouts of these entities the bill also
allows the FDIC and the Federal Reserve
to continue to come to the aid of
financial failing firms which means that
the financial markets will be fully
aware of the government's authority and
inclination to prop up large failed
financial institutions the very
existence of this Authority undercuts
the claim that the government will
actually ever wind up with such firms
these firms along with their creditors
and shareholders will take more risks
and yes
put the financial system in even greater
danger now there's also been much
attention paid to the creation of
something called a Bureau of Consumer
Financial Protection be cfp I would hate
to try to pronounce that acronym this
sounds like a good idea at first we all
want we all want everyone in this Senate
wants to ensure strong consumer
financial protection that's not the
issue yet rather than working with
regulators to strengthen existing
existing consumer protection rules and
crackdown on unfair deceptive and
abusive abusive practices this provision
adds another layer of bureaucracy and
financial regulation that will
ultimately be harmful for consumers and
I mean all consumers by raising their
cause for financial products and
limiting the types of financial products
and services that are available to
choose from not only that this bill
increases the regulatory burden for
banks including our community banks that
are already subject to 1,700 pages of
regulations in just the consumer area
alone under this bill our community
banks would have to comply with an
additional 27 new or expanded
regulations including new burdens or
small business loans no telling how many
pages these new regulations will add or
how much they will increase the cost of
lending to small business finally this
bill harms the very innovation and
entrepreneurship that has made our
country so successful and creating one
of the strongest economies in the world
it does this by limiting the ability of
small start-up companies to raise seed
capital currently angel investors that's
quite a name but angel investors those
higher income individuals who would like
to invest in a promising start up
company take the risk if you will must
have a net worth of at least 1 million
bucks or income of 250,000 this bill
increases those requirements to 2.3
a million and 450,000 respectfully
estimates are that this provision along
with the provision in the bill that
would subject startup and investors to
fifty fifty different sets of state
regulations would disqualify about
seventy seven percent of current
investors in 2007 these individuals
invested 26 billion dollars in more than
57,000 ventures across the country we're
talking about companies such as Amazon
Google Facebook all all benefited from
angel investors yet this bill makes it
harder for promising young companies to
get the capital they need to get started
to grow and become successful at a time
when the unemployment rate is nine point
seven percent I think the last thing the
Congress should do is to make it more
difficult for small businesses to start
up and be successful small businesses
are as the president has acknowledged
the leading job creators in the country
mr. president anyone everyone all of us
agree we need better regulation of our
financial system however the financial
regulatory reform bill that came out of
the Banking Committee does not achieve
that goal I dearly hope that the
chairman of the committee and the
ranking member can reach some
accommodation to produce a better
product it does not address the problems
as written that led to the financial
turmoil but instead imposes additional
regulatory burdens on our community
banks and financial institutions that
did not contribute to that turmoil it
does not discourage risk-taking by large
financial institutions it does nothing
nothing to address Fannie Mae or Freddie
Mac which had a central role in the
collapse of the housing markets that
helped trigger the financial crisis it
does not ensure that taxpayers never
again have to bail out a failed company
however it does increase the federal
bureaucracy and make it more difficult
and costly for consumers to obtain
credit for their families in small
business senator Enzi at a recent lunch
just told us that he had actually read
word for
werd the 268 pages that follow the 10
million dollar criteria in regards to
what this board or this council or this
group will be responsible for and oh by
the way who have we seen come in in the
halls of Congress to talk to individual
offices but Harley Davidson they're
worried about funding for their
motorcycles Dennis doctors we have boat
manufacturers we have car dealers
ninety-six percent of their funding
doesn't come from the automobile dealers
they come from somewhere else they're
worried so as the news goes out and
people read the 268 pages everybody has
start has to come to the to the
conclusion that this is built this is a
bill like an octopus it reaches out into
anybody any business that wants some
venture capital or a loan or some leg up
to start a company this approach will
not benefit consumers or community banks
or our economy we need to work to
improve this bill it is vital for our
economy that we get it right when
addressing financial regulatory reform
because the consequences will be seen
for years for years to come Thank You
mr. president senator from Connecticut
mr. president I take a few minutes see
if I can recognize myself with ten
minutes if I may and ask the chair to
notify me when that time has expired the
chair will do cinematography well mr.
president I have great affection for my
friend from Nebraska and she had his
comments about the bill and he wants to
fix the bill well I that's a that's a
low noble goal and the way to fix the
bill of course is to begin debating the
bill so I'm delighted to hear they want
to fix the bill the problem I've got us
I can't seem to get enough people on the
other side even let us get to the point
where we might give them an opportunity
to do exactly what they claim they want
to do I mr. president with Ed just happy
to hear me just for a second just as I
Kansas I I very privileged to represent
the state of Kansas Kansas excuse me
I've asked is fine that they I apologize
to my colleague I mean they're football
teams are a completely different having
a basketball you do very well in
ok so it's Kansas Kansas not a site
visit appreciate I thank my friend
anyway my point is going to get to the
bill and and whether it's by Senator
friend from Kansas or Nebraska here we
want to get to the bill if we can that's
all this is about now I'm going to talk
about the bill a bit here in these brief
moments I have before we actually get to
a vote this afternoon on this matter but
but I the American public are sitting
there and sort of stunned disbelief here
we all acknowledge this huge problem
that needs to be addressed but the eight
and half million lost their homes the 79
never lost their jobs the 7 million that
lost their homes the retirement income
that's gone all of the statistics we
know that this financial crisis has
caused over the last year and a half
we've been busy trying to cover the
answers on how to solve this problem in
the future here we are with about 14
weeks left to go before the close of
this Congress with a bill on the floor
of the United States Senate that we've
put together over many many weeks and
months on a bipartisan basis i might add
here it is Madam President and now we're
being told despite the fact that 58 of
us believe we all at least begin the
debate I'm not asking anyone to you know
vote to the bill I'm not asking you to
vote for an amendment on the bill all
I'm asking you is can we be in
discussing this bill out here that's the
job of this body to do so so Madam
President I'm delighted to receive all
the lectures have received from people
about what they like the Builder don't
like the Bill of what they want to add
to her to subtract to it and that's all
very interesting conversation but the
fact of the matter is until we move to
the bill which will be the matter once
again before us this afternoon all of
that talk is just nothing but talk if
you've got an idea on what you want to
change in this bill tell me about it
more importantly let's debate it discuss
it and then vote on whether or not to
add it to this piece of village station
or take anything out you'd like to take
out as well but I can't even begin that
process if in fact you continue to
object to us getting to a debate so
that's really what this is all about I
guess it doesn't pay to get your hopes
up in this town but I was still
disappointed yesterday when we ended up
coming up short with the votes necessary
to proceed to the bill and to be honest
Madam President I'm still mystified by
the reaction of our colleagues yes we've
heard all the rhetoric from the minority
leadership we've seen the thundering
hordes of Wall Street lobbyists
descending on this community have been
paid millions of dollars to do
everything they can to stop this
including the motion even proceed to
debating the bill they've been they've
had a victory yesterday congratulations
to the Wall Street lobbyists you had a
great day yesterday American people
don't have a chance to hear a bill be
discussed that might avoid the kind of
catastrophe that has befallen them over
this past year and a half and yes we're
all familiar with the political
considerations that seem as inevitable
as the sunrise in this community but
still Madam President I just can't bring
myself to believe that every single
member of the minority caucus really
wants to stand with a large Wall Street
financial institutions who are the major
major objectors to this bill going
forward this morning Goldman Sachs
executives testify including this
afternoon before a Senate committee we
all got another chance to understand why
they did feel so why they feel so deeply
wronged by this legislation as Frank
Rich said in the new york times this
weekend and i quote them something is
fundamentally amiss in the financial
culture that thrives on products that
create nothing and produce nothing
except new ways to make bigger bets and
stack the deck in favor of the house and
to quote our prosperity in this country
was built on hard work of generations of
Americans it was grown in the cornfields
of Nebraska and Kansas engineered in the
laboratories of Massachusetts forged in
the boundaries of Chicago and
manufactured if I may say so and textile
plants such as my home state of
Connecticut and it's deeply ingrained in
the American ethos that in this land a
great opportunity you'll build wealth by
creating something an idea a product a
service this economic crisis wasn't
caused by the creators the producers the
small businesses
and the working men and women are women
who abide by that guiding principle it
was caused by some on Wall Street who
wanted to get rich without contributing
a thing by executives who simply come up
with ways to circulate money around in a
large circle taking a piece for
themselves every time that circle spins
operating in the shadows of our economic
structures and the places where
regulators weren't equipped to do their
job firms like Goldman Sachs found ways
to gain the financial system reaping hon
heard of profits and rewarding their
executives with huge bonuses mr.
president understand exactly what these
bankers were doing they weren't just
trying to predict the future they were
betting on the failure of the mortgage
market a failure they themselves were in
a position to cause early this month
national public radio and the nonprofit
journalistic organization ProPublica
reported on another firm a hedge fund
named magnetar this hedge fund Madam
President according to the report saw
the housing market begin to decline in
the year two thousand five bro up
enormous amounts of doomed bonds
composed of bad mortgages thus keeping
the market artificially inflated and
then made huge bets on the failure of
the very bonds they had bought knowing
how worthless they were thanks to this
scheme the housing bubble grew bigger
and collapsed harder magnetar walked
away with billions of dollars in profits
other institutions saw an opportunity to
run the same scheme the American people
ended up paying the price of course as
we all painfully are aware I'm the
chairman of the Banking Committee Madam
President I believe in the vibrant
financial sector of our nation small
businesses need capital and credit there
are many honest people on Wall Street I
believe will helped others to build
wealth in our country so the problem
isn't that these executives got rich
without contributing to America the
problem madam president is that these
executives got rich betting against
America they did it secret where no one
could see what they were doing that
alone stopped them until it was too late
they took outrageous risks with money
that didn't belong to them because they
could in their view by the time anyone
realized what was going on the damage
they caused to the prosperity of our
nation had built over the course of
generations Madam President maybe I'm
naive but I just don't believe that any
senator wants to be on their side in
this debate and you know what I've seen
firsthand there are Republicans who
deeply want to get to this bill and get
it done that's why the legislation we
want to bring to the floor reflects
broad bipartisan agreement this bill was
not written by this senator alone or a
handful of Democrats on the committee
this bill was written large part by the
cooperation of my colleagues both
Democrats and Republicans the bill
creates an early warning system so that
we can see and stop the next wave of
dangerous financial products and
practices before they threaten the
economic stability of our nation it
brings derivatives out of the shadows
and into the sunlight so that Wall
Street is held accountable for its
actions finally it puts a cop on the
consumer protection beat so that
Americans can make smart decisions based
on full of information when they're
planning for their financial futures and
those are their families a Madam
President to listen to the Minority
Leader the main point of contention over
the last week or so the reason is given
for his caucuses to try and kill this
bill as a block is a disagreement over
the provisions of our bill that end too
big to fail bailouts but i have to tell
you madam president i just don't believe
that's the case no fair reading of this
bill allows you to claim with a straight
face that it perpetuates taxpayer
bailouts it's just not true I've
debunked the idea before on this floor
and I'll do it again the morning after
the Minority Leader made that claim
mcclatchy newspapers wrote and I quote
McConnell speaking of the Minority
Leader that accused Dodd of drafting
partisan legislation even though the
Banking Committee Chairman has worked
for roughly half a year with key Senate
Republicans and incorporated many of
their ideas into his bill McConnell also
the billikin continues controversial
bank bailouts but it doesn't end of
quote and if you don't believe the press
reports Madam President here's what our
friend the head of the FDIC Sheila Bair
had to say she as I said is the head of
that organization the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation former legal
counsel to the minority leader Bob Dole
a Republican in good standing I might
add as well she pointed out and I quote
her she saw she shuts down by the way
failed banks for a living she's a
Republican she says the status quo is
bailouts that's what we have now if you
don't do anything you're going to keep
having bailouts further she says it
makes this bill talk about our bill this
bill here it makes bailouts impossible
Sheila Bair says and it should we worked
really hard to squeeze bailout language
out of this bill the construct is you
can't bail out an individual institution
you just can't do it end of quote Madam
President I will speak a little bit
light on my colleagues or others and may
want to be heard I'll ask can you
protect her two additional minutes if I
can projection Madam President but now
in the world the minority leader can
come up with that argument just doesn't
make any sense at all he quoted a course
from the infamous frank luntz memo the
memo of course by frank luntz was
written before the bill was written and
frank luntz his political memo said the
following the single best way to kill
any legislation is to link it to the big
bank bailout so he provided political
recommendations and strategies even
before this bill was written the memo of
course confirms out because the datum
and so no matter what we wrote that was
going to be their political argument
here so the Minority Leader blindly
followed the political memo here make
that argument whether or not it's true
or not is irrelevant just say it often
enough and the old adage goes if you
repeat it often enough people will begin
to believe it despite what the facts are
and so Madam President again the the
language of others but let me just if I
can because sometimes just talking about
it let me quote
from the sections of the bill 20 for the
bill says one creditors and shareholders
will bear the losses of the financial
company to management responsible for
the condition of the financial company
will not be retained let me translate
you get fired and three the corporation
and other appropriate agencies will take
all steps necessary inappropriate to
assure that all parties including
management and third parties having
responsibility for the condition of the
financial company bear losses consistent
with their responsibilities including
action for damages restitution and
recoupment of compensation and other
games not compatible with such
responsibilities section 206 of the bill
in taking action against this title the
FDIC shall determine that such action is
necessary for the purposes of the
financial stability of the United States
and not for the purposes of preserving
the covered financial company ensure
that the shareholders of covered
financial company do not receive payment
until after all other claims and the
fund are fully paid ensure that
unsecured creditors bear losses in
accordance with the proprietor priority
of claim provisions in section 210 here
and ensure that management responsible
for the failed condition of the covered
financial company is removed again fired
if you didn't understand those words and
not take an equity interest in or become
a shareholder of any covered financial
company or any covered subsidiary and
then lastly in the sections
notwithstanding under the provision of
law the corporation is receiver for a
covered financial company shall succeed
by operation of law to the rights titles
powers and privileges described in
subparagraph a and shall terminate all
rights and claims that the stockholders
and creditors of the covered financial
company may have against the assets of
the covered financial company or the
corporation arising out of the status as
stockholders or creditors except for the
right to a payment resolution or other
satisfaction of their claims is
permitted under this section the
corporation shall ensure that
shareholders and unsecured creditors
bear losses consistent with the priority
of claims provisions under this section
we seem to have no problems that we seem
to agree on the problem and we agree on
how to solve
Madam President so again I quote from
the legislation let's get to this bill
Madam President we've written the
provisions that stop too big to fail
forever there are other very important
provisions in this bill that deserve
consideration and again I'm not asking
anyone to vote for the bill at this
juncture or to vote for the amendments
that come up but for the life of me I
don't know how you explain to anyone in
this country in light of what we've been
through that we can't even begin the
debate and discussion and by the way no
two centers are going to write this bill
their hundred of us has serve here and
every single member of this body has a
right to offer amendments and be heard
and as chairman of this committee I will
insist upon that that every member who
has an amendment has an idea will be
heard but please let us get to it Adam
press